If you think back to lesson five,
you'll recall how large and
complex the data standards are.
This is an arbitrary,
human anatomy, physiology, and
diseases are very complex.
To be accurate, and
electronic record must be able
to capture the nuances of care.
To be maximally useful it would ideally
capture most of this as structured
coded information.
How do you do that?
How can you provide busy physicians
with a way to accurately and
efficiently capture such
a complex data set?
That's the EHR data capture challenge,
and it has been with us for decades.
The most common approach is this,
a template.
Essentially an electronic version
of the paper check-off forms
physicians have used for
years in their practices.